In 2017, the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau sued the Student Loan
Servicing company Navient, alleging it
steered borrowers away from generous
income-based repayment plans. Media
coverage of the suit immediately and
overwhelmingly sided with the CFPB. But
recent evidence in the case shows why
some healthy skepticism may be in order.
The alleged victims, it turns out, were
informed of income-based repayment — some
as many as thirty times. They either didn't
want it — one called it "stupid as f***" to a
Navient representative — or didn't follow
through on paperwork, or didn't qualify.
CFPB's witnesses were also caught lying
to Navient. Or failing to pay their
government loans while making payments
on luxury automobiles. Others refused to
provide income documents to Navient, or
were wealthy, which is why they weren't
eligible for the benefits they were
allegedly denied. How was a case like
this allowed to proceed  and drag on for
years? Because in this case, lawmakers, the
courts, and a credulous media have given
too much deference to the CFPB.
Who do you think has the stronger case: Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau, or Navient?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.